tiens problème théodore pèlerins depuis
votre road entre andy ou vous avez
incarné une adolescente victime
d'intimidation votre caire a
littéralement explosé j'ai fait un
calcul rapide donc en septembre avait 23
ans
ces 24 films sans télé série tournée ici
et ailleurs
comment vous vivez ce grand
étourdissement je ne vis pas comme un
étourdissement ça a toujours été comme
ce que je voulais j'aime beaucoup
travailler
puis quand j'ai commencé à travailler à
comme 16 ans était vraiment parce que
j'avais un besoin de faire quelque chose
de ma vie j'étais comme une espèce de
moment où j'avais acheté je t'attends
les bêtes dette à l'école peut rien
faire j'ai besoin de m'en faire quelque
chose puis ça a été pour moi un espèce
de cette es vraiment épanoui cement l'on
commencé à travailler puis commencer à
prendre peut-être dans un milieu où
j'avais l'opportunité de constamment est
en apprentissage m en évolution et
effacement chez vous c'est qu'en fait
votre carrière est un accident causé
grâce à vos parents la chorégraphe marie
chouinard et votre part denis perrin qui
est peintre
mais c'est mes parents qui m'ont poussé
quand même allez allez passer l'audition
dans les cas à l'école robert gravel à
ce que ces tests est pas loin de chez
nous puis
parce qu'ils disaient que ce soit une
bonne chose de faire du théâtre à
travers l'adolescence moi ça me tentait
pas j'avais envie de gerber envie d'être
dans une école on a privé j'aime chez
quelqu'un qui aime l'ordre je quelqu'un
qui aime j'aime être étudiant j'aime
faire des devoirs j'aime quand les
choses sont classés non j'avais envie
d'aller dans un espace d'étude de grand
a hérité comme ça me tentait après ce
geste avait passé l'audition puis à
doris opigez me sentais vraiment la
place puis j'ai juste envie d'être mieux
envie d'aller là quand même étonnant
parce que vous dites que vous aimez
l'ordre quelque chose de ranger ouais
mais pourtant morose ce sont des
personnes qui sont pas du tout ranger
désorganisés où c'est le cas où
finalement j'aime l'extrême de ça aussi
je pense que j'aime pouvoir comme
justement peut-être parce que je suis
pété un mois dans la vie qui est très
ordonnée encore aujourd'hui
oui oui mais alors je me sois aussi
comme l'extrême de pouvoir me laisser
aller complètement dans cette non cette
débauche la caméra puis dans ses
extrêmes là dedans c'est nrj la
différente aux explosifs
ouais j'aime ça
j'étais vraiment bouleversant dans le
film chiens de garde de sophie dupuis il
est encore plus dans l'autre film de
sophie dupuis qui doit sortir bientôt
souterrain mais le lien commun entre ces
deux films c'est que vous jouez toujours
comme si chaque rôle était votre dernier
pourquoi parce que ces séquences vous
êtes à saint-antoine mais peut-être que
sa fille se fit demande se fit écrit
comme ça aussi se fit ce prix
ces films sont très émotifs choses qui
se passaient très on rentre vraiment
dans les personnages c'est vraiment
centré sur ces sur ses personnages le
film de sophie donc peut-être que plus
l'espace à aso halloween c'est
l'interview vidéo vous qu'êtes vous êtes
dans le dernier film de philippe
falardeau
mon amie salinger vous pouviez pas dire
non à ce rôle parce que vous m'avez
semble-t-il
vous êtes un admirateur de la pose de jd
salinger oui oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais en premier je peux pas dire non
parce que vous sifflez falardeau pékin
falardeau veut travailler avec l'autre
tu dis oui j'adore fait les falardeau je
l'admets puis ensuite j'ai dit ça nan je
sais c'est vrai j'avais découvert j'ai
des salons de jeux pour le film genèse
de philippe lesage où mon personnage
dans ce même le lisais à travers le film
ça mais je dis moi j'ai découvert donc
pour ça pour l'api j'ai beaucoup aimé
donc c'est sûr qu'après ce faire un film
où le personnage normaction de juillet
où le personnage est vraiment obsédé par
le personnage de ron crawford en
l'attrape-coeurs c'était comme c'était
une bombe on le sait vraiment un
personnage mythe si vous êtes souvent
dans vos valises entre les états unis et
le canada
jusqu'à quel point la série american and
coming up in central florida pour
changer votre vie professionnelle et
financière parce que c'était une méga
série positive partout
c'est sûr que ça change un peu quand est
liée d'une série sur un grand network
avec leurs danses
c'est sûr que le tce est parti un peu du
paysage télévisuel la boll donc ça
permet d'avoir peut-être plus axa accès
plus facilement
mais j'ai pas vu un changement radical
le principe pas non plus une série comme
game of thrones qui a été vendue partout
que de gagner des amis série avec un
succès raisonnable comme très bien utile
je suis très fier de ce sommet c'est pas
c'est pas une expérience qui change
radicalement la vie tant que ça je pense
puis alors pas vrai merci beaucoup merci
à vous
[Applaudissements]
une